hey guys welcome to the third episode of
flashback Friday in today's episode I'll
be taking you through one of the most
popular and widely discussed
technologies machine learning but before
that make sure to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell item to get
notified every time we upload a video in
a nutshell machine learning uses
mathematical algorithms to learn and
analyze data to make prediction and take
decisions in the future today
machine learning algorithms enable
computers to communicate with humans
autonomously drive cars write and
publish match reports predict natural
disasters or find terrorist suspects
machine learning has been one of the
most commonly heard buzzwords in the
recent past so let's jump in and examine
the origins of machine learning and some
of its recent milestones the concept of
machine learning came into picture in
1950 when Alan Turing a pioneering
computer scientist published an article
answering the question can machines
think he proposed the hypothesis stating
that machines that succeeded in
convincing human that it is not indeed a
machine would have achieved artificial
intelligence this was called the Turing
test in 1957 Frank Rosenblatt designed
first neural network for computers now
commonly called the perceptron model the
perceptron algorithm was designed to
classify the visual inputs categorizing
subjects into one of the two groups in
1959 Bernard Boudreau and Marcin Hawke
created two neural network models called
adilyn's that could detect binary
pattern and madelyn that could eliminate
echo on phone lines the latter had a
real-world application in 1967 the
nearest neighbor algorithm was written
that later allow computers to use very
basic pattern recognition Jarrell DeJong
in 1981 introduced the concept of
explanation based learning in which a
computer analyzes data and creates a
general rule to discuss unimportant
information during the 1990s work on
machine learning shifted from a
knowledge driven approach to a more
data-driven approach scientists began
creating programs for computer to
analyze large amounts of data and draw
conclusions or learn from the result now
let's talk about some of the
and achievements in this field in 2002
using a combination of machine learning
natural language processing and
information retrieval technique
IBM's Watson B to human champions in a
game of Jeopardy in 2016 google's
alphago program became the first
computer program to beat a professional
human using a combination of machine
learning and research techniques since
the start of the 21st century many
businesses ventured into created machine
learning projects Google brain alex net
d face deep mind open AI Amazon machine
learning platform and ResNet are some
large-scale projects taken up by
top-tier companies Amazon Netflix Google
Salesforce and IBM are dominating the IT
industry with machine learning machine
learning has came exponentially in the
recent decades as the quantities of data
we produce continue to grow so will our
computers ability to process and analyze
it so that is all for this episode of
flashback Friday like and share the
video if you find this interesting we
will be back with another technology in
the next episode until then keep
learning and stay tuned to simply learn
[Music]